and save it. So we are recording right now. Hello everybody. How is everybody today? So we are
going to be sharing the some questions that everybody said did. It is the 27th of, I think it is
September 2018 and I did get to see a movie last weekend. I'm not going to tell you which movie it was
but maybe you'll figure it out from our presentation. So questions that we had come in,
I adjusted them a little bit if this is your question to take off your name. But first one,
hi, keep hearing from my dentist that a code beam CT scan is very low radiation and I shouldn't
worry so much about that just get it done. Any thoughts on this? And what can a person do to help detoxify
from this before and after? Well CT scan is going to give us radiation plus a CT scan could give us
other toxicities if we're using any contrast. I'm not exactly sure how much radiation a code beam
CT scan does versus a different type of CT scan for instance. An abdominal CT scan gives you
equivalence of about 50 to 60 x-ray equivalence of radiation. So that's a lot of x-rays.
A thoracic would give you the same amount. A head CT is going to give you a lot of radiation and
also you have to look at where you're getting the CT because what organs are going to be damaged.
Certain types of tissue are going to be more sensitive to radiation than others.
The first one is going to be neurological tissue. So if you're going to get a head CT
scan you're going to have more damage to the brain or the neural tissue dead if you had an abdominal
CT scan. So you're going to take that into consideration too. But all at all you do have to weigh out.
Sometimes there's the only way that you can visualize something is through a CT and MRI won't pick it up.
A CT is the only way to do it. So you've got to weigh that out. And really where the radiation from
a CT scan causes more issues is number one if you've had a number of them. So getting one or two
CT scans in your lifetime isn't going to be a cause of cancer in a person most likely.
I've had patients that have had a CT scan every three months for a year or so and so this is
and then some other CT scans is their eighth or ninth CT scan. Then you start really
being concerned you're getting a lot of radiation that's enormous amount of radiation.
So the number of CT scans is an important configuration. Also there is a gene,
your CAG gene, that if you have defects on one of or more of those genes or four genes in
those family, you're going to be more susceptible to sensitivity to radiation at EMFs.
So if we've already run your genes and we don't remember if we've gone through that or not,
just email me so that I can look at your genes or call the office and we can look at your genes.
And I can give you that data. But that is another thing to consider. So if you don't have a lot of
defects on those four genes, then you're going to be less susceptible to the damage of the radiation
side of the CT. Now if a contrast is being used also, then you want to address that. So first of all,
going through this again, number one, should I get a CT? Well, is it the only way to really see what's
going on? And that's going to dictate the treatment protocol, then maybe it's a good idea.
But then factor in, is this my sixth CT? Maybe it's not such a good idea.
Is this not going to factor into my treatment protocol? I'm not going to do anything about any
how it was just for the doctor's curiosity. Well, then don't get the CT scan. But if it is going to
factor into, if you're, remember my rule. So in any testing, if it's an invasive test, you don't
do the test. If you're not going to follow, if it's not going to change the way you treat the patient,
but you do the test, if it would change the way you treat the patient. You don't do the test just
to satisfy a more of a curiosity. You do the test to dictate a treatment protocol that may change
if the results came back positive or something like that. So I'm not against doing
imaging. Imaging can be extremely beneficial, and it can rule things out and change the way you're
going to treat something. But then you get to, now what should I do to help detoxify it? So we
do have a radiation homeopath that can help. However, nothing's going to be perfect. So taking a
radiation homeopath is going to pull a radiation out of your body, but it will certainly help.
So if I was going to do a CT scan, I would do the radiation homeopath. And you can start after
you do the CT scan, you can start a week before you do the CT scan. If you're getting a contrast,
we have Galileo contrast homeopath that's the only contrast homeopath that I have right now. So
I would need to know what contrast they're using. And if I could get it to make a homeopath
out of it for you, I will do that. So what would you do to detox? You'd use a homeopath to pull out the
contrast, use a homeopath to you to pull out the radiation, and then you'd support the liver detox
pathway. So the pond one pathway is the most important pathway to support in helping pull out the
contrast. So that would also dictate part of my decision, whether I'm going to get an MRI or a
CT scan with contrast is how are my detox pathways? And if you don't know your genetics yet, you don't
know the answer to that. But if you do know your genetics and we've gone over that, then you know
how healthy your pond one pathway is or your NAT one and two pathway or cytochrome P450 pathways.
So if you need to review on that, just call the office and schedule a time for me or for Anne to go
over that quickly with you. So that's how I would work on detoxifying it. To detoxify the pathways that
that contrast is going to go on on, use a key later in a form of a homeopath or some other key later,
like what if I'd sit respect it or a key lax which has EDTA and DMSA in it and to help pull that
out of your body once you're exposed to it. I need to get a dental implant done, terrified that
they that it will poison me. So that's a good thing. So dental implants are typically titanium
and typically everybody there could be exceptions to this but typically people don't have reactions to
titanium. So I know there are some new techniques in dentistry where they're using porcelain as the
implant. There's only a handful of dentists that are doing that and that tends to be almost nobody
reacts to that but I have not personally had anybody ever in my office that had a reaction to
titanium. I've had people react to all sorts of metals, metal implants for bones,
nickel and different metals that they use for surgery, post surgery, for reconstruction,
bone reconstruction, had all sorts of horror stories about that. I've never had any horror story
with titanium. So I you know as much as you know I wouldn't be excited about getting that done
to myself because I just don't like doctors. I don't know that I would be really scared about that.
If you do have you know great concern about that and I know who asked this question is a local patient
if you could get a piece of the titanium for me to test you on and we could test you on it to see
if you're going to have a reaction we might even be more confident and moving forward.
As far as detoxing I don't think you're talking about detoxing the titanium implant but you are
going to have to have surgery which is going to be some medication that they're going to put in for
anesthesia however they're going to put you out for the surgery and yes we're going to want to
detox that. So we detox that similar to what we talked about here with CT skin. We want to know
if it is a specific product that we can create a whole new path out of that that will help
and secondarily supporting the different detox pathways. What can I do by body ramping up the
histamine issue with trying to heal? The histamine will be ramped up not so much when you're trying
to heal you could have an increase inflammation of an histamine ramp up because of a reaction to
the anesthesia or something like that but the biggest thing that's going to be ramped up when
you're trying to heal is your amtore pathway and your IGF1 pathway. It's difficult to slow that down
with anything specifically but there's some things just supporting autophagy that will indirectly
slow down the amtore pathway. So we can talk about that if you do if you go forward with that.
Next questions. Is there any rife programs to run on eczema besides the one titled eczema? So
I have not had a lot of success running the rife programs on eczema for eczema.
What we've had success with we ran a lot of success with eczema in looking at some of the possible
causes of eczema. Common causes of eczema are heavy metal toxicities and as we improve your detox pathways
and as we start pulling that out the eczema tends to improve however so we got to look at the
causes. A person can have rashes in eczema because they're detoxing through their skin
because they have a lot of toxins to detox that are overwhelmed with their liver detox pathways.
So if your liver detox pathways are overwhelmed because of an excess amount of toxin then you
could end up with skin issues. If your liver detox pathways are overwhelmed not so much from an
overabundance of exposure to mercury or something like that but because of a lot of defects on those
pathways so you already have very, very sluggish detox pathways that's the person that has had
eczema since they were a kid on and off. Typically they have a lot of genetic defects on their
detox pathways so they always had very sluggish detox pathways and the truth is if that's you
that you would have done very poorly on today's vaccination schedule where if you're 50 years old
you received probably six vaccines when you were a child. Today's children are receiving 40 to 60
vaccines. The amount of toxic exposure to heavy metals and dangerous chemicals that they use as
adjebugs in those vaccines are what are causing ADD, ADHD, aspergers and all sorts of problems
brain-based issues for these kids and the kids that it's causing problems with are the kids that
have these kind of defects. They don't detoxify these chemicals very quickly at all so they end up
settling in the tissue and since little babies have no blood brain barrier they cross the blood
brain barrier and toxins are going to settle in fat cells more readily than any other cells and
they're going to settle in the brain and they're going to cause all sorts of problems so if you were
bored if you have eczema issues and you were bored later that you are going to be more prone to
problems because of an increased exposure to toxins and even today we're exposed to more toxins,
take vaccines out of the picture that we were as little kids just because there's more of the
environment. So you want to look at supporting detox pathways with eczema and I would consider doing
more of the footpath programs with the clearline detox for the eczema. Also there's some topical
things that can be extremely helpful for eczema because many times it's a biotoxin so using
grapefruit seed extract, not grape seed extract but grapefruit seed extract can be very beneficial.
You could get that in a pill form or a liquid form. We have them both in their store
or you could buy them online at Amazon as well and those are that can be a good product by putting
a couple drops on your figure and rubbing it on the eczema. Cannabis oil can be very good,
CBD oil can work well on eczema. Rick Simpsons, THC oil, if you have that put a little drop and put
that on the eczema. That could be extremely beneficial for eczema. Also we have the walk about
EMU oil that could be beneficial for eczema. The curcumin cream could be extremely beneficial for
eczema. These are all topical things that I'm talking about. But as far as running a rife program,
I would say do the footpath with some of the detox programs are going to be your best bet for eczema.
What are the most powerful protocols we can do to get CT PET skitter and the rye out of our body?
Well, I kind of went over that supporting the detox pathways and if you are using
a contrast with these, which most likely you are, then if we could use BAKO homeopaths for those
contrasts and support the pod pathway and the NAT pathway, that's going to be our best bet to get
that out. Also go back to trying to pull it out other ways besides taking some pressure off of our
liver can be extremely beneficial. So using the footpath can be very beneficial. Using a sauna can
be very beneficial. So that's the benefit of that. So use the detox programs in that. And then the last
question here would medicinal mushrooms potentially feed yeast or Candida. Potentially, yes, I have not
had that happen. I don't think that's a problem. It's not, you're not giving it a fungus. If you
have Candida, you really shouldn't be eating mushrooms, but the medicinal mushroom blend is a dried
mushroom. It's not going to have the same issue. So no, with Candida and yeast, you want to be careful
with sugars for sure, mushrooms and those types of foods, but the mushroom blend should not be a
problem at all with that. And then some children are getting life threatening illnesses. Oh yes,
they are. A lot of more children are getting cancer than like crazy here. Is there a reason not
to have the Navarro HCG urine test done proactively for a child? And if you don't know what the Navarro
HCG test is, that's a urine test that you do that you've said off to the Philippines. It takes a
while to get the results back, but they give you a score and it tells you whether you have active
cancer or not. It's a very accurate test. We've had patients do that very regularly and have
really good success with it. So it's a very accurate test to do. And I don't know what they
recommend age-wise, because it is measuring human-choriotic, good antitropid, hormone. And I'm not really sure
what age limit there is. I would think if I would have to look that up, but I would think that if
they're over 10, you could certainly do that. Questions that came in? Could the homeopathics for
the CT scan detox also affect the effectiveness of the chemo? No, not at all. So it's just totally
different. It's homeopathic specific to the radiation. Number two is what in one of the videos Dr.
Connor says the rife will revert cancer cells to standard cells. So yeah, so how does the rife work?
Is it really reverted a cancer cell to a standard cell? Well, let's understand what a cancer cell
is. It's your normal cell that's in a rapid reproduction phase. And if you could get it to stop
reproducing, then it really isn't called a cancer cell anymore. It's just acted as a normal cell.
Yet in the article he wrote in the protocol, it says rural rife had experience with the kids,
the kidney cancer cells. So yes, there's multiple ways that the rife works. So therefore,
I'm not sure which is right. Well, in both of them are right. If reverted to standard, it does not seem
like a good idea to debulk the prostate by lasering out perfectly good cells. Well, that is true.
And I understand your issue. My prostate is enlarged. And it's causing issues because of
its enlargement. If does this mean that I will have this condition of the rest of my life and
then I'll have to catheter the rest of my life, et cetera. The only answer to that is honestly,
it's going to be time. It's going to tell. So on some cancers, so let's just talk about the prostate,
but this goes for every cancer that it's actually going to shrink. So as your body is starting to
break those cells down and it starts to go through apoptosis, it's going to shrink. On some,
it's not going to shrink. It's just going to stop growing. And it's going to stay that same size.
Now, if that's true with prostate cancer and you're already catheterizing, it may not shrink. And
we're going to have to talk about either removing that surgically doing some surgical intervention,
some sort of stint put in catheter the rest of your life. Yes, so that is a possibility. So
only times going to tell on that answer that question. But multiple ways cells die
when you're treating cancer. So lysis, cell apoptosis,
or the cell just starts functioning as a normal cell again and it stops reproducing,
or the cell dies and the body walls it off. Now, that doesn't, I've not had that happen with prostate
cancer. I've happened that happened many times with breast cancer and quite frequently with lung
and liver. That's a quite common occurrence. And then you are just going to have a mass there that's,
you know, like you see a mass at seven millimeters across in the liver and it stayed that way
for the last seven years. So that means the body's just walled it off and it's just dead tissue
on the inside of there. And if you wanted it to go away, you'd have to surgically excise it. So
we may have to use some other intervention in that case. Okay, so I am going to unmute everybody
and open it up for questions if there's any other one. So you everybody is unmuted
unless you mute yourself. So if you do have questions, you can ask them. I'll be careful
with you. I'm going to put it out of the background. Dr. Connors, this is Deborah Swartz.
We have the industrial wind turbines going up around our home, approximately 160 or
probably going to be built if we don't get them. Anyway, the EMF's coming off of these things. How
much danger, how dangerous are they? I have not seen any figures on what those are producing as far
as electromagnetic frequencies. I don't, you know, I don't think that it would really be a big EMF
issue. So wind generator is just generating electricity. They're trying to prevent as much loss
as possible and it's going right into the system. So I don't know that it's going to be a big EMF
production. There's other environmental factors I know with it. It's kind of ironic that everybody
was screaming like blazes with B.P. oil spilled out of oil in the Gulf and all those animals passed
away and it was horrible, horrible thing for the environment. But what they didn't tell you is all
they have down at the Gulf, in the water, they have all these wind turbines, just crazy about
a thousand wind turbines or something. And they happened to build those in the migration
line of certain birds. There's more birds and animal flying animals killed from the wind turbines
in one year than that B.P. oil disaster happened. So that goes on year after year. So trying to do
things wisely to produce energy doesn't always work the way we wanted to work, unfortunately.
So we're not always as friendly to the environment. Now I have heard rumors of other issues with the
wind turbines. And point us, I can't recall what they were. I can't remember if it was an EMF issue
though. I think there was other issues with it. But I can't recall what they were. So I have to look
that up. You could look it up to just Google. And maybe they do produce a lot of EMS. I'm not sure.
The problem with EMFs and trying to get rid of EMFs in your environment is it's a nightmare because
we're exposed to so many EMFs. We could use things like the products of static products that we have
in our store. We could use support for our cell phones and our computer devices. But nothing is
going to block all EMFs in your environment. It's just not possible. So, and then now what's really
scary thing is the 5G that's coming out with our cell phone system. There is belief that that's
going to cause an enormous amount of disease that our cancer rates are going to really spike with
this 5G technology. There's no knowledge of what's going to happen. We just got to pray that it's
it's not going to be as bad as we think it is. Okay. They just have these really huge huge
just if you want to say telephone poles or electrical poles, they're like three times the heights of
the wooden or the tree ones. And the lines on them are unreal. So that's why that's going to produce a
lot of, you know, that's just in the in the lines that are carried electricity that's produced. That's
going to produce a lot of EMFs. And I'm sure they have a transformers that are changing the
12 volt to what 20 to carry it and such. So that's going to produce a lot of EMFs.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We have also added a lot of, I'm trying to say, electrical power stations.
Right. Yeah. It's not a good thing. All right. Thank you.
Dr. Connors, this is Ken Rosen trader from Alaska. There was there a couple of weeks ago. Uh-huh.
And maybe this is too personal or narrow a question to ask, but I'm just what you probably don't
remember because you write so many protocols. But I just wonder if you might happen to remember is
in the one you wrote, did any of them address chronic kidney disease?
I do remember and it didn't. I just mentioned that to Michelle because I saw you email that question.
Oh, okay. Thank you. Right. So I think we're going to send you another flash drive.
We'll update your program. We'll put that in and we'll send you a flash drive with instructions
and how to download it in the computer so you'll have it. So there is a possibility of help.
Well, of course there is. Well, I didn't know how far it went. So that's how it could tell your do here.
Well, I just didn't know how far rife went. That's great because the whole conventional wisdom
in medical field is once kidneys are hurt that can't be healed. Well, I know that that is and it's
because you got to finish the sentence that they don't finish. It can't be helped with drugs
that they have right now. So your body can't get healed. So we're going to get there. Okay,
this is very encouraging. Thank you. Okay. I won't take it any more time. Thank you.
I said chat question about if you're getting gassy from certain foods, does that
alone tell you you shouldn't be eating those foods? And you know, for example, onions, garlic,
peppers, cabbage, those are the typical gassy foods.
It means you need to tell me after you eat that so that I don't hang around with you.
So that's necessarily. So with the with the
audience and the sulfur-containing foods, if you get really gassy from those, it can be because
of a deep defects in your trans-alpheration pathway to CBS genes because you're just
don't be that really quick. However, it can be and more than likely is do more to
enzyme deficiency in your gut. So if you just tried to take a digestive enzyme when you eat those
foods and see if that makes a difference, I would try that first. Is that what like the gas
sex and everything is supposed to do? Yeah, what gas sex is just an enzyme?
Okay. So there isn't anything wrong with using that. There's just some better enzymes on the
market. But using a digestive enzyme with when you eat your meals is very beneficial.
Matter of fact, there is a really neat research paper that came out last year with
pancreatic cancer. And because just pancreatic cancer is like any other cancer has been
on such an enormous rise. And the paper spoke about what are the thoughts of why the rise of
pancreatic cancer is because our diet has been so poor that our pancreas has had so be
up-regulated to produce enough enzymes to break down foods that it can't do its job. The average
size of the human pancreas has gotten larger over the last 50 years or where they got all that
data, but they went down through post-bortum studies. And that was one of the things that was
hypertrophied pancreas, due to trying to make it an enzyme that it can't keep up to. So
taking digestive enzymes could be extremely beneficial for not only digestion, but it takes a lot
of pressure off your pancreas. So I assume you have a product that would be better than gas.
We have numerous digestive enzyme products. So it really depends on any other issues
the person's having. So we have a digestive enzyme with HCl in it. So that's if you have
you know you get a tummy, you feel like you get a little tummy ache after you eat or you feel like
your food is kind of sitting in your stomach. You need some help with hydrochloric acid
and I shared my entire screen here so I could actually just go to
our store and show you these. And we have, so if that's not an issue and you just want a
straight digestive enzyme that I would typically use the digestive enzymes, we have several brands.
One of my favorite, oh I got them as the featured brands here too, so it's easy. My favorite brands
are the US enzymes because I know the guy who runs this company personally and he's like so crazy
anal with perfection, like drives you nuts. Myself and a friend of mine are the ones who develop
the sun spectrum and US enzymes makes it. So I wanted to develop the product with them because I
knew we were going to get like there's going to be no product on the market that's like it. So that's
a US enzyme product, the sun spectrum is. But so they have multiple enzymes, they began as an enzyme
company, right. They have this cleanse enzyme which is really good to help detox with your liver
and such. The D3 enzyme, I'm kind of fazing out because we're going to have a talk on D3 next week.
The protein enzyme, that's a protein powder that is absolutely the best protein powder on the
market. This is the HClzyma. So if you feel like food is kind of sitting in your stomach and not
going any farther, and then the digestimes are the this product right, let's see where it is
right here. So this one is a really, really good digestive enzyme that if you just want to help with
digestion, take some pressure off your gut, help cleatote your gut. This will help break out anything
that's cake to the inside of your gut walls. That's a great product to take. With meals or an empty
stomach to help break down your gut. Okay, any other questions? So what movie did I see this week
The Incredibles. Did anybody else see it? No. What? Oh my gosh, where is your super suit?
I thought twice. Oh, right. That's good. That was a great one.
Dr. Connors, I have a quick question. Going back to the enzymes, I'm a type one,
is independent diabetic of like 32 years. And so since one of the major functions of the
pancreas is digestive enzymes, is that something that I should be using on a regular basis? I don't
normally have problems with indigestion or digesting my foods that I've ever noticed, unless I'm
eating a heavy meal like really late at night or something. So type one diabetes is an autoimmune
disease. Your pancreas has two different types of cells in it. One that makes insulin, one that makes
enzymes. It's type one diabetes is an autoimmune disease where you have antibodies against the
cells that make insulin, not the cells that make enzymes. So if you have type one diabetes,
does that mean that you really should be on enzymes? No, it doesn't. However, should everybody
be taking enzymes? Probably yes. So it does take pressure off of your pancreas. And even though
it's not the cells that are making insulin, it still takes pressure off your pancreas. So
okay. So is there like a general one that you would use? This is a general one, but it is like,
there's a way I like it so much. It's like the best general one that you could think of.
So this is, I take this one. I also have the HCL's in at home, but I don't take that very often.
Since I used to be, would I eat meat? I don't eat any meat anymore, but would I eat meat? I used
to take this. Or before this company, before I use this company, I used a company called standard
process. They have a protocol, a zi-pan, which is a good product too, but it just doesn't hold a
candle to this. I used to take that if I ate meat or if I had a bowl of ice cream or something,
I get a stomachache after it. Well, I don't eat dairy anymore, and I don't eat meat anymore. So I really
don't take this very often. I don't feel that like, oh, I got something like what I just ate,
it was too much, kind of sitting in my stomach. I don't get that feeling anymore, so I hardly ever
take that. It should, should I be specifically tested for these, since I tend to have issues with
anything I take by mouth? Yeah, we should. We could do this, it's tested on you. So I'm just called
and tell Jen or whoever answers that. Okay, great, thank you. All right, so next week, we are not
going to have a live Zoom call. We will be posted a Zoom call, but it won't be live, so you
won't be able to get out next week, because it is the fourth of July. So you'll see something posted
on Facebook, but it won't be something you could ask questions, but you can ask questions
on the emails. So just email me questions into the subject line, put Zoom call question or
Zoom call or something like that, so that I catch it. Remember, literally I get 100 to 150 to 200 emails
a day, and if it could get buried. So if I don't see Zoom call question on there, it's definitely
going to get buried, and even if you do it, it might get buried, and you have to make sure you
remind me again. But so it won't be live, but we'll get a Zoom call posted up on Facebook.
Feel free to keep asking questions on Facebook and utilize that and help answer other people's
questions, and one of the biggest things that I ask you is that you become a prayer warrior for
everybody. I think I posted, maybe I don't think I posted it on the group page. I posted it on
just the Connor's clinic page, I think. This little boy, he has to be about two years old,
and I can't remember, I think he has a horrible kidney disease, or liver disease.
Poor little guy, the mom was washing him at his tub, and she was talking to me, just
turned with the saddest little face. I just think of him literally since I see that video we could
have a go, think of him every day, and it just just makes me not worry about my day so much,
and my struggles, or my pain, or my problems. It just reminds me just to pray for that little guy,
and then I have reminded to pray for all you guys, because that's where we really see the power
in our life, and see God use us in different ways, and we see healing come in our life when we
start turning our needs inside out, and start praying for others. So we've had this week and the week
before, some trials in our family of patients that they're going through things that may not have
the greatest outcome. We don't know, but we need to be prayer warriors for one another. So if I
get this to encourage you to do that for one another, I think that you'll be blessed because of that.
All right, so thank you guys very much. We will talk again very soon, and
continue to send in your questions. Thank you. And go see that movie.
I'm good night. Bye-bye. Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks.